der mit europäischem haftbefehl gesuchte
ehemalige katalanische regierungschef
carlos putsch dem mont ist in
deutschland festgenommen worden
sowohl sein anwalt als auch das
landespolizeiamt schleswig holstein
erklärten der katalane sei an der
deutsch dänischen grenze festgesetzt
worden nach angaben des anwalts war
putschte mont auf der rückreise von
finnland nach belgien
der oberste gerichtshof spaniens hatte
am freitag strafverfahren gegen putsch
dem mont und weitere regionalpolitiker
eröffnet ihnen drohen bis zu 25 jahre
haft putschte mont hatte im oktober die
unabhängigkeit kataloniens von spanien
ausgerufen und damit gegen die
verfassung verstoßen darauf leitete die
justiz ermittlungen wegen rebellion
gegen putsch dem mond und andere
führende separatisten 1 rutschte mont
floh nach belgien ins exil